[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a América este es el
magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad todas las noticias y las
historias de nuestro continente y esto
es lo que vamos a ver hoy
por primera vez en la historia un
expresidente de Estados Unidos se
enfrenta cargos criminales un gran
Jurado de Nueva York decidió procesar a
Donald Trump por los presuntos sobornos
a la actriz de cine para adultos Story
Daniels para que ocultara su relación
extramarital
visitaremos Brasil porque el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro regresó a su
país tras permanecer los últimos tres
meses en Florida el ultraderechista
abandonó la nación suramericana tras
perder las elecciones frente al
izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
y había permanecido fuera en medio de
investigaciones por su papel en el
asalto a los tres poderes por parte de
sus seguidores en Brasilia y vamos a
Ecuador ya que el presidente también
está en problemas la corte
constitucional aprobó que se inicie un
juicio político en el congreso con miras
a la destitución de Guillermo lasso por
su inacción en un caso de corrupción les
contamos desde quito
Y empezamos una vez más Donald Trump
garantiza que su nombre esté en los
libros de historia el ex mandatario es
el primero en ser procesado
criminalmente un gran Jurado de Nueva
York decidió imputar al Magnate
republicano por los presuntos sobornos
pagados en medio de la campaña de la
presidencia de 2016 a la actriz de cine
para adultos stormy Daniels para que
ocultara una relación extramarital que
sostuvieron en 2006 el ex mandatario que
está casado desde 2005 con melania Trump
ha negado dicho romance tras ser vetado
en Twitter por incitar el ataque al
Capitolio Trump creó su propia red
social social y Desde allí reaccionó
estos matones y monstruos de la
izquierda radical acaban de procesar al
presidente número 45 de los Estados
Unidos de América y el favorito por
mucho para la candidatura por el partido
republicano a la presidencia de 2024
Este es un ataque a nuestro país nunca
visto antes es así mismo un ataque
continuo a nuestras relaciones antes
libres y justas Estados Unidos es ahora
una nación del Tercer mundo una nación
en grave declive Qué triste no solo es
el primer exmandatario estadounidense en
enfrentar esta situación tiene muchas
otras primeras veces es el primer
presidente sin haber ocupado otro cargo
público ni militar el primero en haber
sido sometido a un juicio político en el
congreso con miras a su destitución o en
pitchment no solo una sino dos veces a
los republicanos les inquieta que se le
inicie un proceso por pagos a una actriz
porno y no por otros investigaciones
como el intento de presionar a
funcionarios de Georgia tras su derrota
en las elecciones de 2020 o su papel en
el asalto al Capitolio por ejemplo Por
lo cual Trump asegura que es una
persecución una cacería de brujas en el
siguiente informe les explicamos en que
se sustenta este tormentoso caso en su
contra
130 mil dólares es el monto que llevó a
Donald Trump a los libros de historia se
trata de un dinero que supuestamente su
ex abogado Michael cohen entregó de su
propio dinero a la actriz de cine para
adultos Story Daniels para que ella no
revelara en plena campaña a la
presidencia de 2016 una relación
extramarital que sostuvieron en 2006
según las leyes de Nueva York pagar por
silencio no es en sí mismo un delito el
delito consiste en que el reembolso a
cohen fue encubierto la organización
Trump lo anotó como un gasto legal en su
contabilidad según documentos judiciales
la Trump organization autorizó pagos a
cohen por un total de 420 mil dólares
para devolverle los 130 mil dólares
obligaciones tributarias y una
bonificación luego cohen dijo que el
dinero había sido entregado a Daniels es
por eso que el caso se sustenta en la
forma en que la organización Trump
registró el reembolso para cohen pues la
falsificación de registros es un delito
menor en Nueva York el dinero habría
salido de los pagos de sus
patrocinadores por lo que representaría
además una violación de la ley de
financiación de campaña estadounidense
Trump
se le dará la oportunidad de aparecer en
La Corte pero no va a ser arrestado sí
será citado lo que significa que se
tomarán huellas dactilares se le tomará
la foto pero ciertamente no va a ser
esposado no va a estar en una celda con
la población común el servicio secreto
lo va a escoltar a Nueva York donde él
terminará el proceso y hará una
aparición en la corte sus abogados dirán
que se declararán o culpable Así que lo
espero ninguna resolución antes de un
juicio y vamos a ver el juicio más
politizado en la historia estadounidense
Trump ha negado previamente tener
conocimiento del pago realizado a
Daniels la actriz rompió el pacto del
Silencio en 2018 en una entrevista para
sixty minutes en la que daba detalles
del Magnate y decía que la comparó con
su hija ivanka
nos vamos a Brasil porque el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro tomó la
decisión de volver desde Estados Unidos
a Brasilia donde lo recibió una multitud
el ex mandatario de ultraderecha
abandonó el país antes de que Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva tomara El Poder y
antes del asalto a las sedes de los tres
poderes por parte de sus seguidores
ahora se convierte en el líder de la
oposición mientras se adelanta una
investigación por su papel en dicho
evento Andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
con ovaciones de sus seguidores así fue
recibido en Brasilia el expresidente
Jair bolsonaro que llegó este jueves al
país luego de pasar tres meses en
Estados Unidos decenas se acercaron a la
sede del partido liberal formación
política del ex mandatario para saludar
a quien considera el líder de la
oposición bolsonaro en su primer mensaje
desde su llegada a Brasil arremetió
contra el actual mandatario Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva
mostrarle a estas personas que por el
momento y por el corto tiempo que él ha
estado en el poder el no podrá hacer lo
que quiera futuro con nuestro país
Nosotros somos prácticamente el 20% de
los asientos en el congreso además de
otros compañeros que están acá de otros
partidos es un gran honor haber
regresado
el partido liberal de bolsonaro tiene la
bancada más grande en la cámara y la
segunda en el senado tras las últimas
elecciones pero a pesar de su fuerza
política bolsonaro tiene que enfrentar
varios problemas legales entre los que
están la supuesta protección a miembros
de su familia de acusaciones de
corrupción el difundir desinformación
sobre el Kobe 19 también se le acusa de
difundir desinformación sobre el sistema
de Voto electrónico de Brasil así como
de filtrar información clasificada y por
último Pero no por ello menos importante
se le acusa de incitar a la revuelta sus
partidarios que invadieron el Palacio
presidencial el congreso y el tribunal
supremo tras su derrota electoral además
de esto la semana próxima deberá
presentarse ante la Policía Federal para
esclarecer su conducta con unos valiosos
obsequios que recibió Arabia Saudita y
que no entregó al estado y que
alcanzarían un valor de alrededor de 3
millones de dólares vamos ahora a
Ecuador porque la corte constitucional
dio luz verde a que el congreso inicia
un juicio político con miras a la
destitución del presidente Guillermo
lasso en un caso de corrupción se le
señala de no haber tomado medidas para
detener una trama para asignar cargos
públicos dentro de su círculo cercano se
necesitan 92 votos en la asamblea para
destituirlo el mandatario afirmó que es
inocente y que la oposición quiere
tomarse el poder escuchemos su reacción
soy inocente
en mi vida personal profesional y
pública siempre ha actuado con recta
intención por tanto
rechazo este juicio político
que huele muy mal y me da la impresión
que algunos asambleístas
se han inventado un juicio político
porque buscan el poder de manera
desesperada respeto la decisión de la
corte constitucional
aunque no la comparta
y vamos a Quito con el corresponsal de
France 24 Gustavo Ortega Gustavo de qué
se trata el caso contra el mandatario
ecuatoriano
al presidente de la república Guillermo
lasso se acusa del delito de peculado el
dictamen de la corte constitucional no
admitió dos acusaciones por conclusión y
si admitió únicamente el presunto delito
relacionado a crímenes contra la
administración pública a Guillermo lasso
se le imputan presuntos actos de
corrupción con colaboración de ex
funcionarios y de su entorno más cercano
a través de una supuesta red de
corrupción alertada por su ex secretario
anticorrupción y del ex gerente de la
empresa pública flopep ambos despedidos
por alertar de estas irregularidades el
peculado es cuando un funcionario
público utiliza un bien del Estado para
beneficio propio o de tercero la
acusación contra el presidente de la
república se refiere a la empresa
pública flota petrolera ecuatoriana
flopep y a la contratación de buques
para el transporte de petróleo Pero qué
dice el expediente del caso
la acusación infiere que el ex gerente
de la empresa pública y el almirante
Johnny estupiñán alertó al primer
mandatario en dos oportunidades de
manejos irregulares en contratación de
buques para transporte de petróleo con
la empresa amazonas tanker pool según
las acusaciones el presidente conocía y
consintió los contratos a pesar de ser
perjudiciales para la economía del
Ecuador el expediente menciona que
Guillermo lasso a través del gerente de
las empresas públicas Hernán Luque
distrajo dineros públicos En beneficio
de la empresa amazonas tanker el primer
mandatario deberá enfrentar
inevitablemente el juicio político y
defenderse ante el pleno de la asamblea
nacional donde la posición al gobierno
es mayoría Guillermo lasso insiste en su
inocencia y que la posición intenta
hacerse con el poder pero los votos eran
los que decidan el destino de la
presidencia del primer mandatario y nos
quedamos en Ecuador una nación que
además de esta crisis política está
siendo asolada por el actuar de bandas
criminales que se disputan las rutas del
narcotráfico las autoridades han
decomisado tal cantidad de
estupefacientes que ya no tienen
capacidad para incinerarla por lo que
han empezado a experimentar con ella a
través de una técnica denominada
encapsulamiento toneladas de alcaloides
son compactados en rellenos con los que
se construyen bodegas veamos el informe
estos obreros van a construir almacenes
sin usar los materiales típicos para
construcción en su lugar utilizarán
droga decomisada al narcotráfico
se le llama técnica del encapsulamiento
y consiste en pulverizar los
estupefacientes con químicos y concreto
para moldear capas de suelos el teniente
Paulo está a cargo de vigilar el proceso
lo que nosotros generamos es una
respectiva orden de servicio que nos
permite evaluar el riesgo para evaluar
este riesgo nos manejamos en varios
indicadores ya sea la cantidad de
personas que van a asistir al proceso de
destrucción la cantidad de sustancia y
especialmente la distancia de donde sale
la sustancia
hoy llegan tres toneladas de cocaína
custodiada por la policía para el
procedimiento de pulverización Ecuador
Es el tercer país del mundo por debajo
de Colombia y los Estados Unidos en
decomisar sustancias ilegales según el
informe de las Naciones Unidas del año
2022 en ese mismo periodo la policía
nacional ecuatoriana retuvo 200 punto
toneladas que ahora tienen nuevo
utilidad cuando esta piscina o esta
celda de seguridad sea completamente
llena va a ser puesta una capa extra de
concreto y como lo vemos posteriormente
servirá para bodegas de la propia
empresa no para otro menester 400
toneladas de cocaína Fueron encapsuladas
por Ecuador desde el año 2018 hasta la
fecha una tendencia que continúa al alza
según asegura este agente policial que
ha pedido proteger su identidad un 80%
Ya que en relación a los años anteriores
Pues hay
hay siquiera hay unas 20-30 toneladas
más de relación a los años anteriores
Ecuador aspiratorgar licencias
ambientales a personal especializado
para proyectar el uso de Esta técnica en
el tiempo el gobierno ha tenido que
crear esta iniciativa porque la
incautación de drogas en el país ha
desbordado la capacidad del estado en
cuanto a incineración traslado y
seguridad gracias por acompañarme en
esta emisión de aquí América por favor
envíenme sus comentarios en redes
sociales a la dirección que ven en su
pantalla en la producción estuvo Laura
Tovar pueden ver esta emisión y las
anteriores en nuestra página web France
24.com
[Música]